the other day me and my wife marcia we
were scouring the bookstore and we found
this one book called
70s cooking party or something like that
and my god what is wrong with the 70s
i mean that's kind of cute what were
they doing in the 70s
what kind of drugs were people on man
scotch egg casserole
they love gelatin it's like they
discovered gelatin was a thing and then
just put it on everything my god man is
it
[Laughter]
ew
god damn what is that
that stop
that's cheese inside of gelatin why
would you do that
ah
honestly that one doesn't look that bad
i could eat that one that one actually
looks good that looks like case cooking
i like that one is that it supposed to
be a christmas
oh god these are so disgusting
it looks like aliens try to cook for
humans and they they just go hey
there you go you like mayonnaise of
course here's a ball of mayo
welcome you new men in your life no
thank you no thank you helmers
mayonnaise stop making trees out of food
why would you do that
that's not entertainment no
stop putting mayo in everything god damn
mayo is one of those things that's
already kind of gross to me and but the
taste is too good to ignore but i'll
have just like the tiniest bit
jack-o'-lantern salad that's a salad
it's shredded carrots
that's actually kind of sick i like that
one actually
ham and bananas
hollandaise
i think this is the one i've decided i'm
going to make i want to know you know
maybe it tastes good maybe we lost a
hidden treasure here of banana ham and
mayo some sauce so let's check out we
are in the kitchen back again to create
some wonderful work
of food we have the items banana
ham
fake ham which honestly makes it
probably even more disgusting somehow
but it's boneless boneless
lemon juice mustard cream lacto-free for
some reason
egg and we have also
our assistant
[Music]
wow you sit there so good
are you looking forward to eat the food
anger
can i have the banana with the
hollandaise
so i actually found the original recipe
the vintage recipe is from contemporary
cooking macau's great american recipe
jesus christ so we're supposed to start
by preheating the oven baby 400 degrees
oh it's fahrenheit
so this recipe is using hollandaise
sauce i couldn't find any so i'm gonna
make my own i've never done that but
let's start with the hollandaise after i
have a little glug glug
[Music]
i found a recipe that says
easy no fail
we'll see about that
i'm melting the butter
it says i'm supposed to use a blender
and have like egg yolk
i assume egg yolk is the
yellow bit right my martial said yes i
almost called marcia maya
all right i got one
why am i filming
edgar's like staring at me this entire
time
looking very cute
that's too
bro i'm just making eggs
i'm making scrambled eggs right now turn
that in the heat
i might have to use the blender after
all is this butter and egg that's it
that's so gross
um they said no fail
no fail
they line
we're gonna use the blender okay
i don't understand
they said three seconds i think that's
[Music]
okay
now
i add butter
oh god
hell
no fail
no fail how what did i do wrong
add butter said
jesus christ
i hate cooking
it's
i'm so bad at it
no food so i i caress my child
he will be all right little hollandaise
sauce
i suppose that boiling water as well
they just added that i don't know where
you're like okay so that look awful this
is i hate this i can't remember supposed
to read an essay blend tablespoons of
hot boiling water add an extra yolk i
don't have the extra yolk you can't just
say that afterwards all right i'm adding
hot boiling water god [ __ ] damn it
damn it
okay
i got the hollywood water boiling bot
water yeah
we're adding it
that's it
for the meme i'm gonna add a dash of g
fuel
that's not right
last one
[Music]
let's do a bit more
i think i should do it more
no
no no no
oh
oh that smells awful
bruh
this is god damn it
how did that happen
ugh
it smells down and it's everywhere i'm
gonna clean it up
no fail no fail sauce
complete
god damn you dutch these are all the
eggs i failed god
okay now we can start with the actual
recipe we got a peeled bananas
easy
monkey
a peel
do i keep the curse a bit of the banana
for the cursed banana recipe i feel like
i should at least try i'll cut it off
i need to speed up man
so i'm supposed to spray lemon juice on
them to make them not brown which makes
sense
banana is such a cursed fruit if you
think about it
i don't like it i don't like anything
like look at that that's already cursed
half a tablespoon of lemon juice to
prevent darkening sprinkle
i feel like i should brush
not sprinkle
right
kay's kitchen in case you're watching
this feel free to use his recipe i will
not be offended
okay this looks like wet bananas
that's not a sentence i thought i'd ever
say
oh god here let me show you something
cute okay saved
[Music]
okay
psychopath
oh my god
i got you
i got you chewing
is there more
you can have the
leftovers trust me again there will be
plenty leftovers
next up we're spreading ham slices with
mustard wrap each banana in a slice of
ham three tablespoon of
why would you add mustard to this why
would you do that god damn it i think
what i'm going to do is have half since
there's six bananas that's half
tablespoon for each so i'm gonna do a
little
this
okay then i'm going to take the banana
give it
this is a bad idea
you know i saw the recipe and you can
tell it's a bad idea but now that it's
really in front of me
i can tell you it's a bad it's a bad
idea this is awful this is bad how did
anyone live it past the 70s man
all right so this is what we got so far
looking hella nice i think
thumbnail i didn't even mean to do that
face
okay we're not done yet but i think
we're almost there uh make sauce in the
meanwhile i've done that okay so i'm
supposed to
cook these for 10 minutes so we're we're
gonna do that now
see you later banana bader
10 minutes
i guess i'm supposed to make the sauce
in the meanwhile but i've already made
the sauce i made the sauce
so i can chill for 10 minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's check on the bananas
not much has changed actually can you
tell
thank you
we shall wait and see
got five more minutes
so i broke my test
mixer
sorry marzia i think it needs to be
thicker so i'm going to whisk it
i definitely added too much water it's
not getting thicker what do i do
damn it well i tried god
damn it marta is watching
it smell burnt nice well from the
machine it actually smells quite nice
it's got that sweet aroma to it
not too big yeah it smells good all
right so here they are my little piggies
my boys
my boys it's unfortunate that i have to
pour this disgusting
cursed sauce but here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
not too bad
five more minutes and it's tasting time
mmm can't wait i'm so hungry
why does he not smell horrible
check this out baby yeah
oh the sauce finally
oh god
six servings baby
are you jealous
that i'm about to
engorge myself and
the mustard aroma really came what is
that
marcia's face
it's so
all right well i mean
it cuts easily because it's banana
hmm
that's
the hidden sweetness
with the savory ham
so good
i can't believe this recipe got lost in
the 70s
like what is it a dessert or a meal like
it's so gross
if it was just a banana
it wouldn't be that bad but adding the
ham to it it's just repulsive
oh god
banana in oven is actually pretty good i
never had it i know that's like a thing
people do they put banana and chocolate
and then they put it in the oven
i would do that
don't do this
yeah strangely enough the mustard
actually helps
[Music]
okay that's it
so that was a very cursed recipe i think
maybe some things do belong in the 70s
after all i've decided to donate this
banana ham banana ram i don't know what
to call it to whoever wants it the most
so write a comment why you want to win
this banana recipe and i will send it to
you i don't want some jokes i want
serious answers only so just tell me why
you want it and what you're gonna do to
it
and uh that's it